hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
as you can tell from my voice i'm just a
little bit sick
but this video is important for you guys
so let's get right
into it we spent basically an entire
month
with all three of apple's new m1 max
including the macbook air
the macbook pro and the mac mini in fact
we've made 17 videos on these macs
since their release so we definitely
have a lot of experience with them
and while we're extremely impressed with
the new m1 chip
there are definitely some problems with
these new apple silicon macs
so in this video i'm gonna go through
the top 10 problems
that we've personally experienced some
of which we haven't heard of or seen
before we ran into them ourselves and at
the end
i'll tell you if it's still worth buying
one of these m1 max
despite these problems getting right
into it the first problem has to do with
external display support as you already
know
you can only hook up one display using
thunderbolt
to these m1 macs unless you use special
adapters and software
and while apple says that they support
up to 6k resolution at 60 hertz
we had some issues with our 6k pro
display xdr
mostly everything runs fine but opening
up the launch pad
leads to a lot of stuttering and dropped
frames
basically every time and i tried it with
both the m1 mac mini
and the macbook pro now i'm not sure if
this is due to some software issues with
mac os big sur
but i ended up trying it again on the
1300
base intel 2020 macbook pro and it
worked
perfectly so it definitely shouldn't be
happening
on these m1 max moving on to problem
number two
while we were expecting the lower end
macbooks to only have
two thunderbolt ports we thought that
the mac mini would come with four
and so far it's been causing problems
because we're already using one of those
ports
to connect to the display on top of that
the mac mini doesn't have any sd card
slots
so we like to use this high speed uh s2
dual sd card reader which connects using
usbc
so that takes up the second port and
because of that
we have to constantly unplug that card
reader to connect something else
like one of our high high-speed
thunderbolt ssds for transferring data
so having four ports would have been
really nice
thankfully the folks over at lwc found
out that each of those thunderbolt ports
on the new m1 mac mini
actually has its own controller which
apparently
support thunderbolt 4 so each port can
actually support
two extra thunderbolt ports using their
brand new owc
thunderbolt hub so as you can see you
can turn one port into three
with the possibility of having a total
of six thunderbolt ports on the m1 max
if you buy two of those hubs but they do
require
dc power so it makes much more sense on
the stationary mac mini but
interestingly
owc says that this hub supplies up to 60
watts of power
so you can just replace your macbook's
power adapter
with this hub if you need the extra
ports we'll leave a link to that hub
down in the description below and by the
way we already pre-ordered one of them
and we'll be testing it in depth for our
full m1 mac mini review
so subscribe right now if you haven't
already moving on to problem number
three
one of our viewers reached out about usb
issues on the mac mini
specifically with them being slower than
they are
on the previous intel models we ended up
doing a bunch of disk speed test
benchmarking
including transferring files to and from
a usb
3 ssd and we found that yes
in fact usb 3 is slower on the m1 max
compared to the old intel versions we
even tested out our dual
sd card reader and files transferred
noticeably slower
which is very annoying i'm not sure if
this is also a software issue
or if apple chose to give less bandwidth
to specifically usb 3.1 for some reason
but someone did test out an owc
thunderbolt dock
and they were able to get the full speed
from their usb 3.1
ssd compared to plugging it in directly
into the mac mini so it's nice to see
that these thunderbolt docks
solve two problems at once now moving on
to problem number four
while final cut pro performance is
absolutely incredible
on these m1 max even beating out our 15
000
mac pro in certain scenarios there is
one
major problem with video editing we like
to use motion vfx plugins
and unfortunately some of them don't
work with apple silicon
specifically plugins like m callouts
which can track
objects and add floating titles don't
seem to work on m1 max
now it could be because of the automatic
tracker which uses
the old mocha engine maybe that's
outdated
and not supported by apple silicon
motion vfx
did come out with a brand new tracker
with a new engine
that is compatible with apple silicon
but they're charging 300 dollars
for the plug-in bundle which is quite
pricey for most people
so this is definitely a problem for
people who are using the older plugins
that can't get updated getting into
problem number five
while apple's video encoders in the m1
max are incredibly fast
outperforming intel's encoders some
users have reported
that the video quality is actually
noticeably worse
encoding basically happens when you
export a video after editing it
leaving you with your final finished
video file
that file seems to have worse quality
after being encoded on an m1 mac
compared to an intel mac at least
according to tom cribbin
who sent us a couple of screenshots so
we're going to be doing more in-depth
testing with encoding and will report
back to you
in the full m1 mac mini review but i do
want to mention that intel is known
for having the best encoders and the m1s
encoders
could still be better than the current
amd encoders in
machines like the mac pro now problem
number six
has to do with gaming specifically
iphone
and ipad game support which is brand new
and
exclusive to m1 max the problem is that
basically all of the games that i was
excited to play
don't show up in the mac app store like
call of duty mobile for example
to get around that i had to use imazing
to download and install the ipa file
and i was finally able to get a bunch of
games to work
like simple games such as clash royale
and clash of clans
with no issues however games that are
meant to be used with touch screens
like brawl stars don't work very well
since you need both hands to move
and to shoot but thankfully controller
support was working
perfectly in games like call of duty
mobile but it's upsetting that some
players are getting banned for some
reason
i do want to mention that i'm using the
latest developer beta of big sur
which allowed me to play those games in
full screen but it's still within the
ipad aspect ratio
so it's not optimized and sadly most
people
don't have access to the developer beta
so they can't even use the apps in full
screen
until the new public version of big sur
gets released and to make it even worse
boot camp support is now gone which
brings us
into problem number seven we no longer
have a good way of
playing popular windows games like call
of duty warzone
valorant and grand theft auto 5. but
games that were already on the mac
like diablo 3 league of legends and
minecraft
run incredibly well under rosetta too
considering the m1 max use integrated
graphics
and games already updated for apple
silicon like world of warcraft
run even better even getting decent fps
on the fanless m1 macbook air however
running windows games is not an easy
task
i was able to play a few of them using
crossover for mac
which emulates windows but among us and
the witcher 3
were the only two games that i tested
that ran very well
games like warzone grand theft auto and
cyberpunk 2077
wouldn't even turn on so i had to resort
to using geforce now game streaming
which wasn't perfect because of
connectivity issues
and this brings us to problem number
eight wi-fi connection issues
these m1 max are the very first macs
with wi-fi 6 support
and it definitely shows since max was
able to get over 600 megabits per second
download speed at his house
compared to around 300 on older intel
max
however i did experience times when the
wi-fi would just
disconnect randomly leading to browser
pages
showing no connection i didn't have
these issues in the past with intel max
so hopefully it's just a software bug in
mac os big sur
that apple is working on solving very
soon moving on to problem number nine
we experience bluetooth issues just like
a lot of people reported online
max swished from his mac pro to the m1
mac mini
and he's been noticing occasional
glitching or weirdness
with apple's magic mouse which never
happened before
on the mac pro i also noticed this
happen myself
while playing games with the mx master
mouse and now
let's finally finish off with problem
number 10.
these m1 macs have been running
incredibly cool compared to intel max
especially for how much performance
they're putting out however
we've seen the temps reach as high as 92
degrees celsius
during heavy workloads now that isn't as
bad as the old intel max
that would easily hit 100 degrees
celsius 20 seconds after starting a
cinebench run
but the problem is that while the m1 max
start heating up
apple is choosing to keep the fan speed
very low
to keep the machine silent now while
that is pretty rare
i've seen the temps as high as 92
degrees while the fan speed
was barely above idle which could be a
cause for concern for some people
who aren't used to temps that high but
luckily for those of you who aren't
comfortable with that
there's an app called tg fan pro which
you can use to set your own
automatic fan profile if you don't want
it to run at temps that high now with
all of those 10 problems out of the way
let me answer the original question is
it still worth
buying one of these new m1 max
absolutely
yes we personally believe that the
benefits of the m1 ship
far outweigh these problems since it
seems like most of them can be fixed
with future software updates the
day-to-day experience on these m1 max is
so much better
than any intel mac we've used before
everything is faster
more reliable and definitely more cool
and quiet
and at this point we would still
recommend either buying an
m1 mac right now or waiting for the m1x
max
which are coming next year and hopefully
by then
some of these software issues will be
ironed out in fact
the only intel mac that we would still
recommend
is the same mac that we recommended
three months ago
the 2020 5k imac for
2300 it's an excellent value
due to the built-in 5k display battery
life
isn't an issue heat isn't an issue and
graphics performance
is excellent so if you want to learn
more details on why we're still
recommending it
go ahead and watch our review of that
imac right over there
and if you learned something new from
this video click that circle above to
subscribe
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]